hello Frank you can call me the doctor  I'm the one who operated on you and the  reason why is simple you killed my  brother this operations your reminder of  the terrible thing you did I have  liberated you from the macho prison  you've been living in good luck Frank  this is your opportunity for redemption  yeah it's me Frank I need to clear my  head  Frank look a little different huh say I  got hired to do this job my mom wanted  to get unit why me  the doctor wanted you the guy you push a  year ago it was a family thing I wanted  to call his Frank kitchen enormous  psychic pain they just speak to this  doctor made a living the way I did one  thing's for sure change is gonna come  I'm still trying to figure you out and I  made enough trouble for you I gave you a  new chance in life you waited  there was anything left the friend  kitchen  it was this point-blank aim  don't forget you  you  you